you cannot be civil you cannot be civil
you cannot be civil you cannot be civil
no you cannot yes this week there was a
new twist in the elitist democrats
hate-filled campaign to divide America
mrs. Clinton said it was okay it's okay
because you know Republicans are
obviously not just wrong they're evil so
go ahead she said keep going with the
rage and the hate keep going with this
and also this keep going with statements
like this from a senior Google executive
quote you are finished GOP you polished
the final nail for your own coffins f
you all to hell I hope the last images
burned into your slimy evil treasonous
retinas and millions of women laughing
and clapping and celebrate I can't I
cannot finish that keep going she said
with campaign ads like this one
encouraging young people to chance for
the rich oh yeah
i'ma change that's a you problem
I'll be dead soon it's just so offensive
and it wasn't just mrs. Clinton egging
on the hate-filled mob other
establishment Democrats are piling on to
Michele which says that you know when
they go
they go low we tip we tip we tickle I
kick him and now with unbelievable
cynicism they're blaming the anger and
hate on President Trump and his
supporters take a look at this
spectacular piece of blame shifting over
MSNBC now the president United States is
holding rallies where angry mobs of
people are demanding to lock up a United
States Senator because they disagree
with her politics but hang on a second
there is a massive difference here Trump
supporters are angry with politicians
like Hillary Clinton and Dianne
Feinstein and they're right to be angry
after the way they've behaved with the
Democrats it's the politicians who are
angry with the people good old mrs.
Clinton started it of course you know to
just be grossly generalistic you could
put half of Trump supporters into what I
call the basket of deplorable zhh
right
the racist sexist homophobic xenophobic
Islamophobic grossly is the word and now
a whole new generation of Democrats is
getting in on the hating game you are
either complicit in the evil you are
either contributing to the wrong or you
are fighting against it
complicit in the evil who talks like
this as well as some old-timers of
course they're getting in on it too they
can't bear to be left out they're not
you have an ally in the White House this
time they have an ally there are small
percentage of American people virulent
people some of them the dregs of society
the dregs of society that is what they
think of you these elitist Democrats
want to be President of the United
States of America well here is a hint
you will never ever become president if
you hate the country you want to lead
tell me what you think of that at Steve
Hilton X and that next rev fnc